welcome to this video playing nico nico
from France Queens gambit him always
transposing to the stone wall in a
rather suspicious way this is very well
known to be good for white it is rarely
played by but strong players let's see
more than one good way to play here yeah
played in a technical let's let's play
them in a technical fashion like this
that's a very simple way to play but it
leads to the fairly typical position
type of this bed bishop against the
night and here black probably should
continue to exchange so I don't think
it's very helpful yes if you don't tell
if you don't take so let's see probably
here to have room everyone I don't mind
the trades here it will always be
slightly better for me so take here
look everyone yeah this is this is very
little of course maybe this was a bit
too technical okay but I don't mind this
type of position at some very
comfortable for white to play with the
pawn on d5 on the color of the bishop
has less always some potential to grind
this position forever okay well this is
surprising putting yet another porn on a
light square oh yeah this I didn't
expect so let's see how to get the Queen
into play now Queen f4 hmm I don't know
I mean he got it he gets a protected
Passover I can locate with 93 but still
this doesn't look great let's let's play
play some slogans and see how how to
maybe get ahead
keeping an eye on the HH square d 8
square maybe even two Queen to e5 it's
not not bad forget the Queen to e5 and
then get the knight on d4 this is quite
a nice configuration I could be this
could be an idea really
okay all right this I didn't consider at
all yeah that's but it's not a bad move
cannot take d 5 because of Queenie one
check made Wow dad that's bad I really I
really should have thought about the
move okay I need some space if it takes
me to i take 95 but of course i cannot
fight for an advantage any more like
this was bad I just need to play some
preparatory moves before before this
action maybe a three or something yeah
but this is risky isn't it Knight to f5
check how do you defend defend this on
g7
now this is this is almost almost over
is that how do you defend it Queen maybe
Queenie six maybe maybe that's not a
mate but it's very close I can take here
and kini ate the check here on c5 you
will go to g8 this is the end of it Jack
you probably need to take and what now
get another check he goes to the seven
and i'm not sure what to do after that
no I can I can just take here but is
this helping me
mmm not clear not clear at all check
damn I don't know he soon I ever ever
have an extra porn but the airport is
not easy not so easy to to play against
I can take here I take out of 784
Oh is there some way to to really drum
up in the tech here I don't know let's
do that check check 40 seconds check
okay my pawn is also rather quick so
this is probably the decisive factor
check and I have this relatively safe
king he does not have any checks after
this he has a check so first check this
one and then d 7 yeah that's promoting
check black resigned well we got himself
into trouble unnecessarily I guess white
by taking on a 2 I really I completely
missed the night be home and I mean this
if if he takes this is just a nice
endgame I can get the night to d4 and
can play this on till hell freezes over
always grinding with the night against
the bishop but this Janice I didn't see
at all it's probably not so terrible the
computer place exactly like I did funny
and now takes 95 he needs to improve
here of course the way the computer
gives me a clear edge anyway which I
find really surprising why why why
should this book be good for white maybe
it's a sub tactical thing hmm
okay I'm threatening this I know but i
thought he can he can just take it if
everything else fails is this so bad ok
king age 7 is with a check so here and
now this yeah it's hard for black to
keep the pants together somehow this
this too I tect it's almost some kind of
looks long if he moves the King I take
take with check if you move the Queen
anywhere I'll take one of the pawns it's
really a big edge surprising and the
computer gives ideas like 25 and
marching the deep on yeah then that was
very lucky I didn't didn't really
consider any of it and i really i really
should play the slower like play this
first or something or do a completely
different route maybe this is the way to
go i was i was a bit hypnotized by this
community 5 idea but it wasn't so so
great at all and then we we got this
check which really looks disastrous but
i didn't i didn't find they made but
it's a it's probably a cocaine check
yeah the point is that Maddie point is
also very quick and of course he has no
palm cover whatsoever for the king yeah
it was a bit I wasn't probably a bit too
pessimistic him okay thanks for watching